Jim jones,
leader of the people's Temple has come to symbolize the ultimate in sleazy evil
cults fingers through a forceful personality,
charm and genuine good works.
He managed to draw a massive following and lead them like a modern day Pied
Piper to the jungles of Guyana.
There you promised them a modern day garden of Eden.
What they found was confinement,
mental and physical control and enforced suicide.
In this week's by and graphics,
we dive into the life of the Real Jim Jones.
James Warren Jones was born on May the 13th 1931 to Lynn,
NASA Putnam and Jim Jones Sr in Crete,
Indiana.
The older Jim was a disabled war veteran,
then NASA was some 15 years younger than her husband's and the marriage was not
a happy one.
Jim was often away working on road crews,
leaving NASA isolated and lonely increase.
She,
it certainly didn't help her cause though with our unsocial manner,
she smoked cast and voiced have to use opinions at every opportunity and that's
uh,
has never wanted to be a mother.
The addition of a child to the family only increased the stress the drains were
facing.
Shortly after the child's birth,
Jim suffered a complete nervous breakdown,
unable to work any longer.
The finances became dire leading to very eviction from the family farm.
The homeless family were taken in by Jim's relatives and the small town of Lynn
and Deana Lynn was a conservative orderly town with the vast majority of the
townspeople being charged.
Guy With the town also has a prominence at Ku Klux Klan membership.
The drones is lived in a derelict shack that lacked plumbing when young Jim
began school at the age of six his mother took a factory job.
This provided the child's with the freedom of before and after school to roam
the streets.
He was a needy child.
He was terrified of his father finding it difficult to make friends.
He spends a lot of time alone reading.
Often the challenge could be seen wandering around town looking disconsolate.
Elderly widows around town felt sympathy for the young Waif fans would invite
him in for a piece of cake.
The boy was so polite.
He soon one the mover.
It was through one of these local matriarchs that Jim got his first exposure to
religion by the way of the Church of Nazarene.
Jim was constantly attentive,
even quoting scripture back to the elderly woman to his mother's ambivalence,
Jim began attending church with the old women.
He hung on every word coming from the preachers mouth.
He also showed an amazing ability to recite sermons and quote lengthly biblical
verses,
but Jim was not exclusively committed to the Church of Nazarene is natural
inquisitiveness caused him to attend every denomination in town.
During the week he would wander into the woods and prop himself up on the stump
where he would proceed to do deliver fiery sermons of his own to the local
forest animals.
This was pretty far outside of the norm and it was just one reason why people
would remember young Jim Jones as a weird kid.
His great interest in religion led to an equally obsessive fascination with
death.
There were also other things that set Jim apart from the other kids in Lynn.
He cries a lot and he also,
he swore 40 much he would also steal candy from the local store.
Further his odd religious obsession,
let him you come out with all sorts of strange things such as that he was being
held down by the angel of death.
By the age of nine,
Jim was claiming 50 amps,
special powers.
One's eight he climbs on a roof and cool down off everyone to watch him fly,
catapulting himself from the roof.
He promptly fell to the ground and break his arm.
About that same time Jim took see wandering around town and is collecting road
kill in order to give each dead animal an elaborate funeral.
The other kids looked onto this with a morbid fascination.
Jim was 10 years old when America and to the Second World War while all of his
school mates spends their recess playing,
there's marines or Gis.
He insisted on playing the Nazis,
particularly their leader at all,
fiddler with whom he was absolutely enraptured.
He even went so far as recruiting younger children and telling them into mini
storm treaters.
When they did not use step high enough,
he would whack them with a twig.
What'd he became?
A teenager.
Jim's new favorite topic changed from religion to sex.
He established himself as the young peoples,
all authority on the subject and we'd set up caught on his porch to teach the
facts of life in my new to detail,
to an eager audience.
It's mother was happy for him to share his dbs knowledge,
but the parents of the other children,
well,
they were rather incensed at high school gym set himself apart,
not just by his strange beliefs and by a strange actions,
but also by his dress rather than the casual dress that was normal.
He walked his Sunday best every single day.
He also never spoke unless he instigated the conversation.
However,
he did love to engage as teachers in debates attempting to highlight his
superior intellect.
Now,
although not in any sense a talented sportsman,
Jim was an exceptional organize that at the age of 14 he established a baseball
league.
During one team meeting.
Some kids saw Jim drop a pattern dog from his loft to its death.
After that it's the players.
They became scared of him and the League fell apart.
By the early 1940 is Jim senior had become a hopeless alcoholic.
His body was now ruined and as he had suffered a stroke that left him unable to
speak legibly.
Then that's a,
took another man,
a secrets that was not so secret in this small town.
Inevitably the marriage irrevocably broke apart and Jim and Lenexa were divorced
in 1945 then NASA took Jim and his move to Richmond,
Indiana while attending high school gym works.
The night shift as an the anthem read memorial hospital in December of 1948 he
graduated with honors,
which was quite an accomplishment for a 17 year olds who was also working a full
time job.
It was while working,
it's read memorial that Jim met,
courted and fell in love with a young nurse by the name of Marcellin Baldwin and
was entranced by Jen who was four years her junior and it's the couple were
married in 1949 together.
They moved to Indianapolis,
Indiana in Bloomington.
Masalin founds work as a nurse.
While her husband attended Butler University.
The couple they now found themselves living in the heart of Ku Klux Klan
country,
and it was in the midst of this redneck country that Jim developed a passion for
two things,
racial integration and socialism.
In the spring of 1952 Jim accepted a position as student pastor read some
Methodist church.
He excelled in the role and quickly set up a youth center,
which was open to children of all faiths.
He seen recognize that the way to attract crowds ends,
therefore to increase church donations,
was to adopt a flamboyance Pentecostal style.
Men's make faith healing a central part of his performances.
These performances began to gather wide your attention and before long he was
being invited to preach.
It's conventions and assemblies throughout Indiana and the surrounding states.
Regular services were held at Elmwood temple in Cincinnati,
Ohio,
where he would invite those suffering from ailments to come forward for the
laying on of hands even traveled as far afield as Los Angeles to participate in
a healing convention.
By the Mid 1950s Jones was filling the churches with his dramatic healing
sermons as each one.
He insisted that the audience be completely integrators and the black members of
the congregation sit up front facts,
which further ingratiated him to local black people.
It was his insistence on racial integration within his flock that lends it to a
splits with Jim's church.
Employer should actually is in Indianapolis at the time,
worked strictly segregated and Jim's allowance of blacks was causing real
problems.
Jim,
he quit in disgust and set up his own community unity church.
This soon morphed into wings of deliverance,
which was renamed in 1955 as the People's Temple Full Gospel Church
from the start.
People's temple grew large crowds of both black and white parishioners.
The healing dramas web still the highlight of every sermon,
but Jim's prime concern at to be building a truly racially integrated ministry
in recognition of his efforts to achieve racial harmony.
Jim was appointed in 1960 by Indianapolis Mayor Charles Boswell.
The man has intended his role to be low profile,
but Jim immediately took to the limelight,
appearing on TV and radio programs dramatically proclaiming,
let my people go.
Jones threw himself into the civil rights movements.
Through his efforts of the churches,
restaurants,
amusement parks and movie theaters,
they were all integrated.
In 1961 Jim collapsed as a result of over exhaustion.
He was mistakenly taken to a black hospital,
but when the mistake was identified,
he refused to move.
He even took to making the beds and emptying the bedpans of sick black people in
the wards.
This caused publicity,
which directs and the led to pressure on hospital authorities to desegregate the
wards.
Now,
not surprisingly,
whites controlled churches and businesses were highly critical of this upstarts
preacher who debt to challenge the status quo,
thread swear received.
A swastika was painted on the wall of the People's Temple Church building and to
dead.
Cat was tossed at Jim's,
if not the 1960s the drains is adopted.
Three children of Korean descent.
Jim referred to these children as his rainbow family in an attempt to extend the
rainbow family.
He also encouraged members of his congregation to likewise adopt wat on
refugees.
Now in the early 1960s Jim,
he became obsessed with the prospect of a nuclear holocaust.
In December of 1961 he announced to his congregation that he had a prophetic
dream in which the entire American Midwest had been destroyed in a nuclear
conflagration officer.
Reasoning and magazine.
Ossicle insights holds nine places in the world to hide.
He took his young family on a trip to one of them,
Belo Horizonte in Brazil.
They stayed there for two years.
During this time is distrust and personal hatred towards the governments of the
United States intensified.
He was convinced that American political and economic self interest had brought
the world to the brink of destruction.
The drains is returned to Indianapolis in December of 1963 Jim immediately made
plans to move his congregation who had been waiting patiently for their leaders
return to another of the nine safe places on the list.
Northern California.
In the summer of 1964 the family along with about 140 congregants moved to the
town of Ukiah in the Redwood Valley area above San Francisco.
Over the next few months,
church services were held in rented church buildings and then as a rancher
Ridgewood throughout the week.
Jim worked as a high school teacher.
After three years of steadily building up its membership for peoples temple was
grounded official standing by the Christian Church Disciples of Christ,
northern California,
Nevada region in 1968 the following February,
the people's Temple,
Redwood Valley Complex Open,
the complex included the Jones home.
They swimming Pol Childcare Center,
old folks homes,
the temple meeting place,
and a ranch.
All of this of course was completely integrators.
This let's all garden of Eden sat in the middle of a strictly segregated Redwood
Valley.
Within a year,
the people's Temple had expanded into San Francisco.
Buses were put onto transport new parishioners there to Redwood Valley for
weekend services.
Jim also took to the road by bus touring from one city to the next,
winning new converts in each place,
many of which were so captivated by the charismatic preacher that they moved to
the Redwood Valley ranch.
People's Temple experienced rapid expansion during the 1970s.
However,
it was also during this time that the church received its first negative media
coverage.
A series of articles in the San Francisco Examiner profiled the church painting
Jones as a false messiah who would claim to bring 43 people back from the debt
if the authority structure,
all of the judge was,
I'll say,
put times of the spotlight,
the examiner articles drew the interest of,
of uh,
media outlets.
From then on,
James came to view the media as the enemy and agents of the devil himself.
Things got worse when in 1973 h prominent members of the people's Temple
defected stories,
image to financial abuse,
mind controlled,
and tax evasion in response to the pressure of brought upon the church by the
media in the defectors,
Jim first proposed the idea of mass suicide.
Such a grandes action would establish the congregants is Matas and shame those
who were out to get them.
As for how,
however Jones his words when nothing more than bluster.
It was during the summer of 1973 that Jones made the decision to relocate the
people's Temple to the South American country of Guyana.
Two months later,
he visited the country in order to open negotiations to purchase 27,000 acres of
lands in the Matthew Ridge area near the Venezuelan border.
The guy and he is cooperative.
Republic was a socialist country and for Jones he would pass through on his
return trip from Brazil in 1963 it was an ideal haven.
The first peoples temple members arrived in Guyana in March of 1974 to begin the
mammoth task of clearing the jungle and breaking grounds for construction on
what was to become Jonestown.
Yeah.
Later there were 50 people's Temple Pine is in Guyana Day and night.
They worked to construct buildings and establish a massive agricultural
projects.
By 1977 Jamestown was an established community,
but things were getting worse.
Back in California.
On Memorial Day 1977 along with 600 congregation members,
Jones made an appearance at a commemoration for suicides who had jumped off San
Francisco Golden Gate Bridge in his address on this day.
He declared I have been in a suicidal mood myself today,
so I have personal empathy for what we are doing here today.
By now,
there was renewed pressure on the church from the American media on August the
first 1977 and also appeared in new West magazine.
It's alleged that members had been beaten,
the church was rife with financial miss dealings and that Jim Jones was nothing
more than a charlatan.
By the time the article hit the new standards,
James was already in Guyana.
By September.
There were more than a thousand peoples temple members in Guyana with only about
50 or so left in the United States.
The sudden influx of people placed severe strain on the facilities at Jonestown.
However,
members enthusiastically pitched into extends the village in order to
accommodate the demand.
Three quarters of the transplanted residents were black with the remainder being
white,
Hispanic,
Asian,
and native American.
The task of feeding housing and clothing the community.
It was a massive undertaking,
but the temple members found a great sense of pride in the feet that they were
accomplishing a utopian heaven on earth.
Despite the harsh conditions and the hard work,
the people appeared in those first few months to be genuinely happy.
Back in California at former members began a concerted attack on the people's
Temple.
A woman who had born a child to Jane's sued for custody of the child's,
which was living at the commune.
Joan's refuse to even consider giving up.
The child's declaring that any attempt to do take the child,
we'd put the life of every member of the people's Temple in jeopardy.
Still other defectors who had left children behind.
Also sued for custody following vis a declaration of human rights violations
committed by people's Temple,
well issued by defectors to the media.
It's included.
The assertion that rehearsals from our suicide often took place at people's
Temple,
a committee of concerned relatives that Jonestown was ms or more than a
concentration camp with armed guards constantly patrolling and the residents
continually subjected to brainwashing forced labor and sleep deprivation.
Attempts were made to pressure Congress to establish an official investigation
of Jones down.
The challenge was taken up by Congressman Leo Ryan representing the San Mateo
district of Northern California.
Ryan had determined to lead a fact finding mission to Jonestown in order to find
out firsthand what was going on that with reporters and relatives in tow,
he flew into the APP or is it nearby Georgetown?
On November the 15th 1978 two days later,
they flew to the airstrip at criteria and then we're driven by limousine into
the jungle towards Jamestown dreams had been repairing the temple members for
the congressman's visit for weeks.
Every member knew that God's were watching their every move.
They were commanded to portray a glorious Utopian society.
Players were conducted in which the members were told exactly what to say when
spoken to you by reporters.
Any signs of dissatisfaction would be harshly dealt with away from prying eyes.
The congressman was warmly welcomed into reception,
was held that first night.
Ryan seems genuine.
The impressed with the organization and the order that he saw,
but late into the night one of the reporters who would come along with him was
secretly passed a note from a man in the crowd,
the man he wanted to leave with the congressmen.
The next morning he report it,
showed the note to the congressman.
Ryan brought the issue up with Jones who declared that anyone was free to come
or go as they pleased.
There's prompted Ryan's.
You make a public declaration.
This,
anyone you wanted to leave with him at the end of the weekends was most welcome.
Over that weekends,
many people came forward.
Then on the afternoon of the second day of the visit or people's Temple member
lunged at Congressman Ryan with a knife.
This event soured the proceedings and the visitors were intends on getting out
as fast as possible.
When the Congressmen's party left,
there were 14 people's temple members with them.
They got into two trucks and were driven back to the ass strep.
However,
the almost immediately after they left dreads orders and the tractor and trailer
man's by armed body guards to follow them.
Just as the congressman reporters and evacuees were about to board the plane and
head back to the safety of the United States,
the truck and tractor rolled onto the airstrip.
It was at this point for Jones has God's immediately opens fire with sub machine
guns.
Congressman Ryan and four others were killed.
Then one of the supposed to defectors pulled out a handgun and began shooting at
those who had already made their way onto one of the two waiting planes.
The leader of the killer guards immediately radioed back to Jones and told them
that the congressman was dead.
It was at this point,
the drains immediately began talking to his followers over a loudspeaker system.
He told them that the congressman had been killed and as a results,
the Soviet Union,
who we had been looking to you for salvation would no longer take them in with
the Americans went out certain descend in armed forces to annihilate the
people's Temple.
He drive fear into his followers by telling them Americans would torture their
children,
rape their women,
and it's brutalize their old people.
The only dignified response he said was to commit mass revolutionary.
We didn't give it to die.
We can enact the revolutionary side protesting the conditions of an angel main
world,
large barrels of cyanide laced Koolaid,
what rolled out and the people began lining up to lay down their lives and mass
protest.
When you have those people trying to beg off,
James told them not to be afraid.
They were simply stepping over to another plane.
That day,
November the 18th 1978 914 members of the people's temple lay down their lives.
Jones,
however,
did not succumb to the cyanide laced koolaid.
He was found with a gunshot.
We into his head.
It was the Tamarind as being self inflicted.
So I really hope you enjoyed that biographics video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel for brand new biographies every Monday
and Thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel.
It's called top tens on that channel.
As you might've guessed from the name of us.
We look at all sorts of interesting top 10 lists.
You can check it out through the link on the screen now,
but if you're looking for something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the archives or indeed a top this video over
there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.